sind wir ganz ehrlich Leute ich und
wahrscheinlich ihr habt auch schon mal
Essen weggeworfen welches eigentlich
noch gut war ob ihr jetzt in den Urlaub
fahrt einfach zu viel gekauft habt oder
aus anderen Gründen einfach mal nicht
anders könnt es ist aber eine ganz ganz
andere Sache wenn das Restaurants oder
Supermärkte machen weil die können
einfach nicht genau planen wie viel
gebraucht wird und so passiert es dass
viel gutes Essen im Müll landet genau
hier greifen Angebote wie too good to go
an dass ich heute mal testen möchte das
ganze ist keine Kooperation keine
Partnerschaft sondern ich habe mich
gefragt wie ist das eigentlich und ihr
habt es Euch gefallen wie ist es damit
zu kochen wie kreativ kann oder darf man
sein beim Kochen und was bekommt man für
sein Geld wir finden es heraus und ich
sage so viel ich musste ein bisschen
planen ich musste schon am Vorabend
auswählen was hier am nächsten Tag
frühstücken will und das habe ich
gemacht und es ist gerade kurz nach
Mitternacht ich habe gerade in der App
geschaut und ich muss mir jetzt schon
mein Frühstück für morgen sichern es
sind nämlich nur noch zwei von fünf
Optionen von dem Frühstück dass ich
ausgewählt habe da so mache ich das
jetzt schnell und dann hoffe ich dass
früher alles klappt ihr seht nächster
morgen also rauf auf die Vespa und ab
zum Steigenberger Hotel fünf Sterne
Luxus aber nicht für uns wir haben es
nur bis zur Rezeption geschafft haben
dort unsere Tüte abgeholt sie sicher ins
Büro transportiert und wir waren
wirklich erstaunt was wir dafür bekommen
haben das hier ist also unser Frühstück
und ich muss wirklich sagen das ist viel
was wir für unser Geld bekommen haben
wir haben eine große Variation von
Backwaren Croissant Schokocroissant 2
Körnerbrötchen ein normales Brötchen ein
bisschen Obst und dann haben wir eine
komplette Platte mit Aufschnitt und Käse
Spezialitäten das ist wirklich stark ich
meine das ist ja auch ein fünf Sterne
Hotel bei dem wir das ganze abgeholt
haben oder der Preis war halt nicht 5
Sterne der Preis war 4,50 € und auf den
ersten Blick kann ich nichts erkennen
was mit den Sachen falsch sein könnte
wahrscheinlich ist einfach die Hotel
Frühstückszeit vorbei und anstatt das
wegzuwerfen kann man sich jetzt abholen
sehr sehr sinnvoll sehr sehr cool zu der
Zusammenstellung muss ich persönlich
sagen ich esse wirklich vieles ich liebe
alles ihr wisst es ja aber das sind
nicht meine persönlichen favorites also
Aufschnitt bin ich kein krasser Fan von
und ich mache ja auch keine Bananen in
Rohzustand Bananen Pancakes und so bin
ich voll dabei ihr hört mich das
wahrscheinlich gerade zum ersten Mal
sagen aber ich kann mir trotzdem weil
das so vielfältiges auf jeden Fall was
Schönes daraus zusammenbasteln womit ich
auch satt werde fürs Frühstück habe
Brötchen oder normales Brötchen ich habe
mir so ein schönes honigbrötchen
schmieren jetzt das feier ich noch oder
krank diese Mini Gläser sind auch immer
cool weil da sollte man das Hotel
Frühstück Feeling aber jetzt in der
eigenen Küche beste Leben das liebe ich
ja krass ne
also die sind nicht mehr komplett
knusprig so kann man auch nicht zu
erwarten finde ich es ist ja klar dass
man in irgendeiner geringen Form
Abstrich machen muss aber so wenn man
weiß dass man das gerettet hat umso
besser
[Musik]
also Notebook jeder hat sich jetzt schon
ordentlich was geschmiert sich
ordentlich was reingegönnt und es ist
immer noch voll viel da deshalb man kann
sagen es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall für
den Geldbeutel und hat irgendjemand für
euch das Gefühl dass das so qualitativ
minderwertig ist
meine 4,50 € zurück Obst ist bei uns
nächste Woche im Kurs irgendwie so alles
sauber na ja wieso du hast die ganze
Zeit auf dem Boden fallen lassen wir das
denn jetzt sauber ist schon dreckig oder
nicht ja da können wir machen das mit
einem wir machen das mit unserem
roborock sauber mit unserem roborock S7
Max V ultra denn Sponsor das heutige
Videos wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
es in so einem großen Büro und so einer
großen Küche relativ schwer immer zu
saugen zu wischen und das ganze sauber
zu halten ich habe den Robo Rock jetzt
schon seit einem Monat und ich benutze
ihn wirklich täglich oder eher benutzt
sich täglich roborock hat mir den
Roboter zur Verfügung gestellt aber hat
mich darum gebeten wirklich ehrliches
Feedback zu geben und ich finde es
wirklich wirklich gut weil jeden Morgen
bevor die erste Menschenseele hier ins
Büro kommt ist schon einmal durchgesaugt
durchgewischt und keiner muss dafür
einen Finger krumm machen der roborock
erkennt durch seine Sensorik alle Räume
im Büro kann alles richtig zuordnen und
erstellt einen Grundriss wenn man es
ganz genau haben möchte kann aber auch
mit dem iPhone mit dem leiderscanner ein
exakten Grundriss erstellen und den in
die App einfügen das wirklich gute ist
dass der Roboter zuverlässig Gegenstände
erkennt ich habe nämlich davor schon
einen roborock auch zu Hause benutzt und
diese neue Generation ist wirklich
schlau also wenn dann Schuh liegt
erkennt er den wenn er ein Kabel liegt
dann erkennt er das Kabel auch es
passiert quasi gar nicht mehr dass der
Roboter sich fest fährt aber die mit
Abstand größte Verbesserung ist die
Station die kannst du über im Haus
platzieren füllst immer mal wieder
Frischwasser nach lässt den Beutel und
der Roboter arbeitet einfach von selbst
holt sich sein Wasser lehrt sein Wasser
aus reinigt den Mord wirklich sehr sehr
komfortabel in der Station befindet sich
sogar eine Bürste die den Wischmop
reinigt also auch das müsst ihr nicht
mehr selbst machen das einzige was ich
machen muss ist alle 4-5 Tage mal
frisches Wasser nachfüllen schmutziges
Wasser ausleeren und sonst mache ich
nichts und das Büro ist sauber also
vielen Dank an Robert ich bin ohne Witz
ein riesen Fan davon ich gucke immer
durch die Kamera wieder gerade sauber
macht und so danke für die Unterstützung
machen wir weiter mit nächsten Video und
danke dass wir einen sauberes Büro haben
gut gesättigt von diesem üppigen
Frühstück hatten wir einige Zeit bis zum
Mittagessen aber auch da gab es wieder
einiges zum Auspacken gleich zwei
türkischen Supermärkten haben wir diese
mystery-tüten abgeholt die jede Menge
Lebensmittel beinhalten wir hatten alles
an Obst und Gemüse was man sich nur
vorstellen konnte Gurken Zucchinis
Auberginen Orangen ganz ganz ganz viele
Kiwis eine Avocado und sogar eine Papaya
bzw zwei Papayas waren dabei ich wüsste
nicht dass ich überhaupt mal so eine
Papaya gekauft habe aber warum nicht das
ist wirklich eine Menge Zeug für 7,50€
kann man sich überhaupt nicht beklagen
eine Sache davon ist in perfekter
Verfassung zum Beispiel diese Birne ich
wüsste wirklich nicht was mit ihr falsch
ist die ein oder andere Sache hat
irgendwie so ein paar Dellen oder
teilweise sowas hier muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen natürlich auch nicht essen
das landet dann zwar bei mir im Müll
aber es landet nicht all das im Müll
sondern nur ein kleiner Teil ich habe
sowas wie Sellerie hier was gut reingeht
das oder das ist das für ein etwas warte
mal das ist scheinbar Mangold das ist
schon mal gut ich glaube ich habe am
meisten Bock das ganze jetzt so in Mixer
zu werfen glaube ich ich mache mir ein
leckeren Smoothie jetzt erstmal komm ich
schneide das ganze jetzt und dann
schmeißen wir das mal in Mixer
was riecht schon so den so einem
überteuerten Kaffee wirklich und
ich probiere erstmal vielleicht muss ich
den Geschmack ja noch verfeinern
es schmeckt halt so gesund auch
irgendwie gut weiß nicht so ganz wo
alles herkommt das hätte ich gebraucht
nachdem wir einen Tag im Auto gegessen
haben weil da habe ich ja nur Fastfood
gegessen hätte ich am nächsten Morgen
diesen Smoothie getrunken es wäre ohne
Spuren an mir vorbeigegangen
sehr lecker ist halt gesund schmeckt
halt gesund ich glaube ganz oft in
Smoothies tun die so als Basiskomponente
Apfelsaft oder so Fruchtsäfte übrigens
green Smoothie 54% Apfelsaft 21 %
bananenpüree ich sag's euch ehrlich ein
paar Schlücke davon und ich fühle mich
schon wie ein besserer Mensch also das
ist wirklich das Thema hat das Gefühl
dass man sich was richtig gutes zuführt
und das Absurde ist dass das was wir
dieses Gefühl gibt eigentlich jetzt im
Müll lege wenn wir es nicht geholt
hätten schon cool ja wirklich
gutes Gefühl so beim Essen bzw trinken
und das ist halt keine bezahlte Werbung
für to go to go sondern es ist einfach
eine nice Sache muss man echt sagen
guckt euch einfach mal an wie viel wir
immer noch haben das ist wirklich crazy
aber die ein oder andere Sache kennt man
so auch gar nicht mehr ne also ist ja
klar dass Gurken auch mal umwachsen wir
machen jetzt weiter mit unserer Suppe
wir machen eine schöne leckere herzhafte
Suppe und ich beginne indem ich ein paar
Tomaten Aubergine paar Sachen im Ofen
unter dem Grill schön anröste den Grill
machen wir auf 220 Grad an dann nehmen
wir uns hier unsere Tomaten also die
sind ein bisschen weich aber das ist ja
nur gut Aubergine
Paprika wenn uns das Anschauen die ist
auch so ein schrumpel ist gereift ist
ein bisschen schrumpelig aber wenn man
halt eine Suppe macht ist ja bestens das
ist ja eigentlich gerade das erste
richtige Video aus der neuen Küche
noch gar nicht so drüber gesprochen wir
sind einfach da wir haben die Küche
jetzt schon ein paar Tage und haben
einfach so unter uns hier schon ein
bisschen Frühstück gemacht und wie auch
immer aber sowas hier zu machen das ist
hammer und jetzt geben wir das Ganze
unter den Grill
so dass die Haut von unserem Gemüse so
richtig schön verkohl in dieses
Tageslicht ist so hell dass ich manchmal
die Steuerung nicht sehe weißt du wir
schneiden Rettich Karotten und Zwiebel
so sieht das geschnitten aus Rettich
Karotte Zwiebel alles was das Herz
begehrt wir fangen mal mit unserer
Zwiebel an Rettich dazu während das
jetzt vor sich hin dünstet können wir
schon mal unser Gemüse aus dem Backofen
okay super guck dir mal den ganzen Sache
wir machen direkt einen Move oh wie gut
sieht das aus und wie gut riecht das
bitte das kommt alles da rein einfach
ehrlich Leute freut Euch auf das erste
100 Stunden Video aus der Küche haben
auch echt viele geforderte haben viele
gefordert wir haben schon was geplant
dann würde ich sagen rein mit unseren
Kollegen von hier drüben oder bitte zu
sagen Rennen in die hohle
sag du machst das super danke schön oh
ach das Geschmack dir
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack guck dir das mal an alter das ist
so purer Geschmack einfach ein wenig
kochendes Wasser damit unsere Suppe und
nicht abkühlt jetzt so viel das alles
bedeckt ist voll geil dass ich einfach
alles hier habe Thymian auch noch dazu
dann würde ich fast sagen bisschen
runter mit der Temperatur so dass du nur
noch leicht köchelt Deckel drauf und 20
30 Minuten warten so sieht das Ganze
nach 20 Minuten aus alles ist richtig
schön durchgezogen ich gehe mal mit
einem Löffel rein
so sieht das ganze fein püriert aus es
hat so eine sämige Konsistenz wie so
eine Kürbissuppe das ist nicht keine
ganz glatte Suppe geworden so jetzt
schmecken wir das ganze mal ab wir
nehmen ein bisschen Knoblauchpulver ein
bisschen Ingwer und geräucherte Paprika
und so geben wir es in unsere Suppe
hinein und ich bin mir sicher dass es so
der letzte Schliff wir rösten uns noch
ein bisschen Brot an das ein bisschen
an und dann richten wir das ganze schön
an
[Musik]
also Leute das ging schnell das ist
lecker und das kommt bestimmt noch mal
ganz anders jetzt so fertig angerichtet
deshalb rein mit dem Löffel bisschen
schön Olivenöl
boah wirklich diese gesamtkreation
geschmeckt die Aubergine du hast die
Tomate aber auch so diese kleinen spices
die kleinen Gewürze die wir am Ende noch
dazu gegeben haben einmal rein mit dem
Brot und jetzt kommt der Moment
das ist eine Suppe könnte einen Namen
haben verstehst du Akzente so ein
Gericht mit dem Namen sein
ganz kurz erstmal ne das hat das erste
Video aus der Küche was wir so richtig
machen könnt ihr es uns jetzt absehen
dass wir etwas gewartet haben und
endlich wieder hier zu kochen ist zu
schön einfach Alter ich will eigentlich
lieber hinter der Kamera stehen jetzt
probier mal bitte ich bin gespannt ob es
Dir schmeckt
Alter die hat so eine Bruch maxdichte
geschmackstiefe ich persönlich bin auch
mehr und Fan von so einer stückigen
Suppe die halt auch noch was mit sich
bringt und nicht so wie jetzt eine
einfach eine Brühe ja okay wir haben es
jetzt ein paar mal gesagt aber das ist
immer noch essen das sonst Weg hoffen
wollen wäre wie ihr gesehen habt habe
ich eigentlich fast noch genauso viel
Obst und Gemüse gehabt ich hätte einen
Obstsalat machen können ein Ratatouille
machen können oder ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz viele andere Sachen und das
zeigt einfach wie viel Vielfalt und wie
viel Möglichkeiten mit diesen Sachen im
Müll landen das ist eigentlich schade
wenn man drüber nachdenkt das ist
eigentlich der große Tenor vom heutigen
Tag die haben mit allen Sachen noch so
viel Verwendung und so viel Freude
gefunden das ist eigentlich vollkommen
bescheuert ist dass ihr Müll landen
natürlich ist es irgendwo eingeschränkt
die Sachen sind vielleicht nicht mehr so
frisch dass man damit alles machen kann
oder es fehlt vielleicht die ein oder
andere Sache aber dann kann man halt
einfach Sachen dazu kaufen so einfach
ist das und man macht einfach was Gutes
zumindest fühlt sich ein bisschen so an
deshalb habe ich heute sehr viel Spaß
gehabt am heutigen Video vielleicht
mache ich das privat auch noch öfters
falls ihr School findet probiert es mal
aus oder lasst es sein wie gesagt ich
habe keine Kooperation mit denen aber
ich fand es cool heute deshalb klickt
bitte bitte hier drüben auf das für euch
vorgeschlagene Video aktiviert die
Glocke und abonniert diesen Kanal wenn
euch die Videos gefallen haben bis zum
nächsten mal danke fürs zuschauen und
tschüss
[Musik]